thank you hello everyone it's a pleasure
to be able to talk to you today
today about apologenic risk or analysis
for alzheimer's disease risk
and the opportunity that this affords
much needed opportunities for
transforming the prospects for
development of new alzheimer
therapeutics
during the course of my presentation i'm
going to be covering
an introduction to the clinical
challenges of alzheimer's disease and
associated drug development
i'm going to be talking about polygenic
risk scores and how they can be used
and specifically how they pertain to the
genetics of alzheimer's disease
and and what we've been developing at
cytoks which is a polygenic risk or
algorithm
with the trade name of genoscore and how
that performs in longitudinal clinical
studies and the subsequent implications
for stratifying
subjects into clinical trials for the
future and the prospects for clinical
trial enrichment and of course that in
turn will
influence very positively we think the
prospects for new drug development
you can see on this slide which
describes the challenges of alzheimer's
disease
the huge problem that we the industry
faces alzheimer's disease
is the most common form of dementia but
it is one of four or five recognized
types
constitutes between 50 up to 70 percent
of dementia
and the problem that the world faces
today is this escalating
problem associated with an aging
demographic in the developed world
the costs today are estimated at
about 800 billion worldwide and they
will
travel by 2050.
and one of the challenges associated
with
the development of new drugs is is
addressing the the failure rate we have
not not seen
any significant new drug approval since
2003
and that's associated with the problems
of finding
the correct subjects for enrolment at
the earliest stages
of the disease where the drugs that were
in are in development have the best
prospects for working
to the point where the screening failure
rate is over 90
in some studies what i'm going to talk
about today is how genetics and
polygenic risk scores in particular can
help
improve that success rate so of course
alzheimer's disease is not purely
a genetic disease and i'm talking about
the late onset form of the disease as
i'll describe in a moment
but actually manifests itself as a
consequence of genetic inheritance
and also exposure to environmental and
lifestyle risks
and that's illustrated on this slide
here
we're all born with a an inherited level
of genetic risk
the question is whether that risk
becomes manifest at the level of disease
simpsons
and as we can see as we get older those
symptoms
can be very mild in the preclinical or
prodromal phase of the disease
and then manifest as clear dementia
later on
whether or not a defined genetic risk
becomes manifest at the level of
symptoms
seems to be a measure of how well we
manage our exposure to other risk
factors and i've listed some of them on
this slide
such as cardiovascular risk hypertension
whether we take regular exercise and
eat a sensible diet whether we have
diabetes or whether diabetes is under
control a whole series of things
that can be managed in a high genetic
risk individual might well push back
the time at which symptoms become
apparent and that's that's very
important in terms of
clinical management considerations going
forward
now there are a number of ways we we
we can intervene to to decide whether or
not someone
is in a high-risk category today by the
use of very invasive and very expensive
biomarkers
but these have significant limitations
so if we look at the left-hand side of
the slide here
we can see uh two curves uh the yellow
curve
associated with normal age-related
memory loss
as we all get older uh our cognitive
functions tend to decline
uh naturally but very slowly
and well some of us will be on that more
precipitous blue and red
curve associated with uh
alzheimer's disease and this is not a
normal aging process
what is happening at the time of those
symptoms or actually about 20 to 30
years before those symptoms
is a buildup of underlying pathology in
the brain associated with amyloid plaque
neurofibrillary tangles and other
pathologies
and and so they we have a window we have
a 20 to 25-year window
where we could intervene therapeutically
uh to actually
affect the the outcome of that disease
process
so on the right hand side of this slide
on slide five uh we've illustrated here
a couple of the techniques that are used
today
in the form of amyloid positive positron
emission tomography imaging
uh which is effective at picking up
amyloid in brains of
uh subjects even pre-symptomatic
subjects
but it's very expensive and at
plus per scan and of course the earlier
you go in the disease process the less
likely you are to find someone with
amyloid and so
typically in clinical trial recruitment
you may have to to carry out
uh 10 scans to find one positive
individual
the other option here is a lumbar
puncture where we're taking out a sample
of cerebral spinal fluid
to look for telltale amyloid and how
protein fragments
but that's actually quite difficult to
do quantitatively and reproducibly
across many labs
and of course it's highly invasive
having to take a lumbar punch a sample
so we've been working on the premise
really set out by professor john hardy
at ucl some years ago the genetic
analysis
would be the most cost effective way of
deciding who should be
assessed using these more invasive
techniques
for early signs of disease development
on this slide you can see actually that
there are two forms of alzheimer's
disease and our focus today is on the
late onset form by far the most common
form of alzheimer's disease probably
upwards of 95 percent
maybe as much as 98 is associated with
late onset by which we mean
uh greater than 65 years of age
there is an early onset form of course
which occurs
uh in families in discrete families and
these are associated with
dominant mutations in the amyloid
precursor protein and the two protein
illegal genes these are very well
documented
late onset disease on the other hand is
associated with apoe
locus as we'll talk about shortly but
also
with a large number of of loci um
throughout the genome these 21 loads i
here
were documented a few years ago in a a
well-known publication
but since then they've been a large
number much larger number uh
identified and these are uh small these
have uh small effects
and it's the cumulative uh effect of
these
these these variants that seem to confer
risk for the late onset form of the
disease so alzheimer's disease
of the late onset variety is associated
with many
dna variants spread throughout the
genome
as of this publication back in 2018
there were over 40 different loci
identified each of which confer
the variance confirm either a little bit
of added risk or perhaps a little bit of
protection for the development of the
disease
you can see on the right hand side here
the aqua locus
is by far the most commonly associated
with increased risk
but depending on where you draw the
cutoff in this so-called manhattan plot
we can identify large numbers of other
risk-associated
dna variants so
to summarize what's needed
on this slide we need we can see that we
need
effective early identification
ideally a pre-symptomatic phase of
at-risk individuals
and the solution that we're talking
about today is
a polygenic risk or approach
and our particular algorithm we call
genoscore which
is driven from a dna sample
either blood or a mouth swab
which is then isolated from that sample
the dna and run on a proprietary array
that we call variatex
we'll talk about that in a moment that
various texas
array is built on a thermofisher axiom
platform
run on the gene titan equipment and then
the output from that array is analyzed
in our software platform our proprietary
platform called snip theta
within which the genus sugar polygenic
risk or algorithm sits
so we get the primary genotyping data
from the array
that's analyzed using genoscore in an
automated workflow
run in whichever lab
we're working with that has to have this
equipment so we work regularly with the
keysogen
in the us with europeans in europe and
we've worked extensively with the
ramashati centre in australia
but essentially we can work with any lab
that has this laboratory infrastructure
okay so the barrier tech 2 array um will
be familiar to some people
uh we um previously uh
had the very tech one array this is a
new version which contains
something like five or six times as many
snips including all the original
variotek
one content plus
optimized snip panels to drive the
polygenic risk or algorithms now the
discussion today is really all about the
genuscore algorithm
but just for information we do have
other polygenic risk or analyses that we
can carry out from the
the basic genotyping content of this
array
and that analysis would be available
depending on
exactly what the experiment was trying
to achieve but you can see here
we've got various panels of snips some
of which arose from our
collaborations at university college
london with john hardy and his group
many of which come from cardiff
university and are optimized to drive
the algorithm
on which genuscore is based we'll talk
about that shortly
and some of them that come from
mtor associated pathways which are from
university of birmingham collaboration
in the uk
which allows to drive other other forms
of analysis
we have an extensive literature panel
covering all the early onset associated
variants
in app psn 1 and psn 2
and of course we have panels that would
allow us to do
pharmacogenetics admin type studies as
well as
imputation if that was required
so the cardiff algorithm on which
genoscore is based
is one of the best published algorithms
that's available
and it has
some very key characteristics it was
trained in a very large
database a very large training set the
so-called igap
consortium data set uh and contains a
very large number of snips so we're
talking here about an algorithm
uh which in this publication uh the best
accuracy was achieved using more than 87
and a half thousand
snips or dna variants actually the the
gina score algorithm that i'm describing
now has got a bit more than that got a
few more 115 000 or so
and we find that this gives us the most
stable prediction
across different data sets relating to
alzheimer's disease risk
in the samples that we've analyzed and
for which i'll show you some data
shortly
a final point on this slide is that
the the validation of the cardiff
algorithm has been done in
completely independent data sets some of
which pathology confirmed which is a
kind of gold standard
for alzheimer's disease definition and
so we know that the performance
is not just due to the overfitting in a
training set but indeed is
preserved in completely independent test
sets which is a very important
characteristic
and you can see some data here
from exactly those uh those sorts of
test sets which we'll cover in a bit
more detail
on the subsequent slides so
um of course the cardiff algorithm is
not the only polygenic risk or algorithm
and i would draw your attention to this
paper that was published last year by
hannah stocker ital which set out to
compare the
performance of different polygenic risk
or algorithms
for predicting alzheimer's disease and
essentially what hannah and her
colleagues concluded was that of the
algorithms available
the cardiff algorithm is the best
performing the highest performing
in terms of accuracy and it's one of
only two that have been
actually tested and confirmed in
pathology
confirmed data sets so that's very
important when dealing with a
a disease which can be quite difficult
to
accurately clinically diagnose without
that post-morse and post-mortem
histopathology correlation
now one of the key characteristics we're
going to look for in any polygenic risk
or algorithm is how it compares
to a setting risk above and beyond apoe4
you will recall that i mentioned a
couple of minutes ago that apoe4 is a
risk-associated allele in fact it's the
most characterized
of the risk associated to alleles in for
late alter alzheimer's disease
but carrying e4 itself or what may give
you an elevated risk but does not in any
way
determine whether or not an individual
will develop alzheimer's disease
so it's important if you are an e4
carrier and this slide illustrates the
the distribution in a general
uh cognitively normal population in this
in this case from the uk
so about 23 percent of the population
carry one copy of e4 the so-called e3 e4
heterozygotes and these would be
considered to be a relatively high risk
but we know that a lot of those people
will not go on to develop alzheimer's
disease
conversely the majority of people will
not carry e4 but will fit into the e3 e3
homozygotes
group and yet we know something like 40
to 50 percent of alzheimer cases
come from that e3 e3 group so we can see
automatically here that
e4 assessment alone will not be
sufficient
to uh to have any clinical utility in
predicting
the future likelihood of developing
alzheimer's disease and indeed that's
the case
now just before i get on to share some
data a little point here that
um we our job really in cytox has been
to take and build on the academic
excellence of the cardiff
uh research algorithm and and turn it
into
a validated product that can be then
used ultimately in the clinic
so for that we've um we've worked across
a number of different data sets um
including able
in australia university of pennsylvania
emory university and others
and we have had to demonstrate
robustness in all appley genotypes
the algorithms the algorithm i'm
focusing on today comes from cardiff
university
but there are others available too that
do slightly different things
for example the algorithm from
university of birmingham that we've
developed
based on the mtor pathway we can talk
about that on another occasion or people
can ask questions about that should they
wish
the array is a customized array built on
the thermo fisher
axiom array platform for reasons of
quality control essentially and we've
got global access by our partners
piezogenes europeans and other
laboratories
so if we begin to think about the data
now um
why would we want to use how would we
expect to be
able to use this type of approach i
think there are several key reasons i
mean one
as i've touched on already is to
identify the clinical trial participants
at the earlier stages who are most
likely to cognitively
to cosmetically decline during the
follow-up period of a therapeutic trial
so this will allow us of course to
reduce child subjects and the associated
costs
and increase the chances of
demonstrating a therapeutic effect
we said already that we would need to
demonstrate a performance above and
beyond that
associated with apoe genotyping alone
we'll talk about that shortly
and of course what would be ideal would
be able to predict
those at highest risk of meaningful
cognitive decline by which i mean a
measurable
objectively measurable cognitive decline
within the period
of a clinical trial follow-up
and then another point on this slide and
the last point actually is to do with
subtype so the expectation is that some
drugs are more likely to be effective in
some subsets of alzheimer's disease
sufferers than others
and this type of analysis uh
lends itself to be able to effectively
identify those genetic subgroups
and therefore enrich in subsequent
therapeutic studies uh in in a way akin
really more to
cancer drug development and the the use
of
prognostic markers
the work i'm going to describe now has
all been
um analyzed using the the so-called acne
data set at me
stands for the alzheimer's disease
neuroimaging initiative it's a
long-running
uh study that started in 2004 and comes
with very comprehensive
longitudinal follow-up data and the
subjects have been confirmed using pet
imaging so that gives us a high level of
confidence
based on the amyloid burden in these
subjects that the
clinically defined alzheimer cases
really are alzheimer's disease rather
than some other
dementia and that the age match controls
really are controls
and not simply um pre-symptomatic
at-risk amyloid alzheimer's subjects
so um most of the work i'm going to be
describing now has been done
in this cohort there are over 630
amyloid confirmed subjects and these are
very well age matched across controls
and subject groups the mean age of about
78
and what we can do in these analyses is
compare the performance of our algorithm
with other
other forms of algorithm based on appley
alone or
combinations of apoi and other other
parameters as i'll describe
shortly so if we look across the
uh acne data set and we ask
how good are we how could his genes
score predicting
clinical a.d from cognitively normal
controls across
all aboui genotypes in other words this
is everyone thrown in together
we can see that if you do that using the
apple we alone
give an auc an accuracy measure
essentially of about 73 percent
the the apologetic risk score algorithm
without a weak component gives you about
70 percent in an apparently independent
measure and if you combine the two
things together uh we come up with an
auc of 80
so that's a significant improvement
above up a week but of course this is in
subjects who
some of whom will be happily for
carriers
so if we ask the question what happens
if we
look at the e4 high risk subset
carriers within this group so these are
the heterozygote e3 e4 carriers
are we able to differentiate relatively
high and relatively low risk
in this group we can see that the um
by establishing cutoffs using our
polygenic risk or analysis
in this case the top quartile fell at
the 0.61 and above cutoff
we have a positive predictive value of
84
at the auc level so that's that's that's
telling us we're able to pick out
the top quarter the highest risk
subjects amongst the e4 carrier group
and these are the people you might well
want to enrich your uh
your clinical trial with and actually if
you take that
that measure down that cut off down to
give you the top 50
you're still at 71 positive predictive
value
and this would be hugely valuable to
anyone wanting to enrich a study cohort
for those most likely to develop the
disease and therefore
the ones that should be recruited into
your clinical study
if we take the other end of the spectrum
the apple e3 homozygotes
who would be conventionally thought of
as having relatively lower risk
we can see here that we're able to uh to
stratify
in this case by taking the lower
quartile with a negative predictive
value of about 89 almost 90
so we could we definitely want to
eliminate those subjects from a clinical
trial
on the other hand if you took the
highest quartile you'd be up at about 50
percent so positive predictive value of
about
51 in this particular study so you might
want to include some of these in your
clinical trial
so that your indication would extend to
those uh
e3 e3 homozygotes
within the the study parameters when the
inclusion exclusion criteria for your
study
so so if we look at the conclusions from
the work i've just described and from
other studies that we are continuing
to carry out right now we can say that
the
stratification of the e4 carrier
heterozygotes
can identify the subset of e4 carriers
at the highest risk of developing
alzheimer's disease
and of course these are the ones you
would want to stratify and enrich
into your clinical trial to measure
therapeutic effect
at the other end of the risk spectrum
the apoe3 homozygotes
our analysis has clearly shown it's
possible to identify the subset of these
individuals at the lowest end of the
risk spectrum and would also allow you
to identify
the higher risk e3 e3 homozygotes
to include in your study design as well
the the algorithm has the potential to
improve
uh the ability to predict individuals
who will convert therefore from mild
cognitive impairment to
ad well over and above apoe alone
and given the
[Music]
observations that enrichment of the
mci and the other prodromal at-risk
subjects
gives you the highest opportunity to
show therapeutic effect this is a very
important observation
and we're doing more work at this on
this very question at the moment using
the admin cohort and indeed using other
cohorts as well
the algorithm clearly has the potential
to select those patients who are
most likely to decline cognitively
within the time frame of the clinical
trial
and that's obviously crucial because
without that
decline in a reasonable period of time
and therapeutic effects are very
difficult to measure
the um it's worth mentioning that our
genus score and indeed other algorithms
are available for research collaboration
uh at this stage and we're working with
a number of pharma biotech and academic
studies at the present time and
going forward we our intention is to be
to be engaging with the u.s and european
regulatory authorities and look for full
marketing approval for clinical version
of our genoscore algorithm
in the 2021 time frame
i want to finish by acknowledging our
team
and other partners very important
partners
a very talented team here at cytox in
the uk
and we work globally with collaborators
around the world
key partners for us as i've mentioned on
route have been the
dementia research institute team at
cardiff university led by
julie williams and valentino rescot
price and
in particular two very talented postdocs
effie bellow and
ghana vienenko and of course john hardy
at the ucl dementia research institute
and mariam show i
again john's postdoc there we've
um of course relies heavily in this
presentation on the acne data sets i'm
very indebted to abny
and of course mike weiner the pi for
abney
and not least all the patients
volunteers and their families who
contribute
very important samples and of course
their time
to commit to the extensive clinical
evaluations that
are very important in
participating in those sorts of studies
our funding at cytokines comes from
a number of sources not least our
investors
but also from grant money we've received
and continues to receive money from
innovate uk
and and we also receive money from
european union
so thanks very much for your attention
and i look forward to answering your
questions in gcourse